[Musique]
papa tu reviens encore à la maison
écoute je t'aime mais il ya des choses
que je peux pas expliquer tu dois me
faire confiance
vincent danse tu m'as volé quelque chose
on le mois où ton fils ne rentrera pas à
la maison
je croyais que ça devait être un coup
facile vient pas du tout facile disons
thomas qui ce qui se passe
vincent à notre fils retrouve le
problème cette ville est infestée
grippaux mesdames et messieurs à crème
du nevada à faire un thème méchant
policière j'aime ça
[Musique]
ça fait deux ans que je suis un filtre
connaissez mais qu on connaît leurs
méthodes
je suis prêt arroser tous les flics sans
exception pour voir vincent times
tu touches à mon fils je te tue
[Musique]
l'ennemi